à dijon au procès de jean marie villemin
la cour et les jurés se sont aujourd'hui
pencher de très près sur la fatale
soirée du 16 octobre 84 le jour de la
mort de grégory et sur l'emploi du temps
précis de christine villemin
compte rendu d'audience dominique
verdeilhan j'hydrate rice christine
villemin s'en rend compte au procès de
son mari les débats depuis plusieurs
jours se focalise sur elle résultat les
regards se tournent vers la mère de
grégory
le public lui même ne s'y trompe pas sur
le visage de jean marie villemin
refilmer exceptionnellement ce matin
avant l'audience
la même fatigue la même appréhension le
même désoeuvrement de voir son épouse
une fois de plus en position d'accusée à
la barre christine villemin revit minute
par minute les moments qui ont précédé
l'annoncé du drame le 16 octobre 84 au
soir à 16h53 j'ai quitté mon travail à
lépanges sur vologne
je me suis dirigé en voiture aux hlm
chez mon amie christine jacquot la
nourrice de grégory puis vers 17 heures
je suis arrivée au pavillon grégory m'a
demandé de rester dehors il voulait
jouer sur le tas de sable
je lui ai fermé son anorak les volets
étaient clos
moi j'ai repassé quelques minutes plus
tard je suis sorti grégory avait disparu
c'était un enfant par soeur espiègle je
me suis demandé s'il ne se cachait pas
il y a neuf ans ils étaient les voisins
de christine et jean marie villemin le
en revanche habite toujours
lépanges-sur-vologne christine jacquot
la nourrice de grégory se souvient que
christine villemin est venu lui demander
de l'aider dans ses recherches
je ne pouvais pas dommage rétorque m
garot vous lui auriez servi d'alibi
témoignages pittoresque avec marcel
claude ont permis hier ce jour là comme
tous les jours elle conduisait à les
tables c'est 36 vaches à quelques mètres
du pavillon du couple villemin redire à
la cour ce qu'elle a déjà dit au juge
lapèze mais elle aussi confirme
christine villemin affolé angoissé
recherchait grégory aux alentours de
17h20
hier accusé christine villemin re
devient aujourd'hui une mère catastrophe
est bouleversé
retournez que décrivent plusieurs
témoins mais demain des collègues de
travail devrait développer une autre
version
elles ont vu christine villemin vers 17
heures près de la poste à une heure où
le corbeau aurait posté sa lettre de
revendication